Ich bin in dieser Bändeerstin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja Frau Doktor, natürlich.
So als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Hans Brenzle.
Hans Brenzle.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen und Vornamen bestabieren?
Hans, H, A, N, S.
Enschuldigung.
Enko.
Hans Brenzle.
Wer ist Hans Brenzle?
Ja, Hans Brenzle.
Hans mit H, A, N, S.
Brenzle.
B, R, E, N, Z, L, E, R.
Ok, danke schön Herr Brenzle.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 82 Frau Doktor.
Ja ok.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ja, 8. Februar 1943.
43.
Ok, ok.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 70 Kilogramm Frau Doktor.
Groß?
Groß 1 Meter 65.
65 und 70 Kilogramm.
70 Kilogramm ja.
Wie heißen Sie Ihre Hausärztin?
Herr Müller.
Ok, danke schön für diese Informationen Herr Brenzle.
Was für Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Frau Doktor, bitte seien Sie nicht sauer, aber Sie sehen sehr jung aus.
Ich würde lieber von einem Chefarzt mit mehr Erfahrung behandelt werden.
Ist das möglich?
Ja, natürlich.
Alle Wünsche sind für uns sehr wichtig.
Aber ich möchte sagen, ich bin nicht sehr jung.
Ich habe mein Medizinstudium absolviert.
Wir arbeiten als Team.
Wenn wir eine wichtige Entscheidung treffen,
treffen alle andere Arzt zusammen eine Entscheidung.
Deshalb machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich möchte sagen, Sie müssen sehr lange warten,
wenn Sie mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Ok, Frau Doktor.
Ich werde alle unsere Gespräche mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Wir werden alle notwendige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ok, ich fühle mich jetzt besser.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Doktor, ich habe viel gelebt.
Ich bin 82 Jahre alt.
Ich habe viel gelebt.
Als zweiter Krieg.
Als zweiter Krieg waren wir aus der Czechostavakien ausgewandert.
Nach Deutschland, mit meiner Familie.
Ich hatte viele müde Zeiten.
Ich fühle mich sehr müde.
Ich möchte sagen, in letzter Zeit.
Ich beginne zu vergessen.
Normalerweise war mein Gehirn sehr stark.
Aber in den letzten 10 Tagen kann ich nicht weg zu Hause finden.
Ich wohne allein.
Ich habe vier Kinder.
Mein alter Sohn ist Pilot.
Er ist sehr erfolgreich.
Aber ich vergesse manchmal die Namen des Enkels.
Deshalb hat mein Sohn mich mitgebracht.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Wissen Sie, wo Sie sind und welcher Tag heute?
Welcher Tag?
Ich denke, Donnerstag oder Freitag.
Ok, Freitag.
Welche Monate?
Welche Monate? Ich erinnere mich nicht genau.
Ok, kein Problem.
Vergesst Sie Ihren Termin?
Ja, Frau Doktor.
Ich habe einen Termin beim Hausarzt.
Aber ich könnte nicht gehen.
Ich habe vergessen zu gehen.
Ok, aber ...
Manchmal vergesse ich zu essen.
Ich habe 5 Kilo abgenommen.
In letzter Zeit oder 10 Kilo.
Ich erinnere mich nicht mein Gewicht.
Ich habe es vor zwei Monaten vergessen.
Aber ich vergesse zu essen und zu trinken.
Wo ist meine Frau? Haben Sie sie gesehen?
Ist sie hier?
Sie ist eine Frau.
Meine Frau ist hier?
Ja, ich glaube.
Wie kamen Sie? Wie kamen Sie ins Krankenhaus?
Mein Sohn hat mich mitgebracht.
Ok, dann ist Ihre Frau zu Hause.
Oder?
Ja, ich habe meine Frau verloren.
Ich erinnere mich jetzt.
Ich habe meine Frau leider verloren.
Sehr leid.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Oder?
Manchmal habe ich Kopfschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Bevor diese ...
Ich weiß nicht. Manchmal seit Jahren.
Seit langen Jahren habe ich Kopfschmerzen.
Jetzt kann ich nicht gut lesen.
Normalerweise lese ich gerne Zeitung und Bücher.
Aber in letzter Zeit kann ich nicht konzentrieren.
Zu lesen.
Ich fühle mich müde.
Meine Haut ist getrocknet.
Ich weiß nicht. Meine Haut ist sehr dünn und getrocknet.
Ich vergesse zu essen, trinken.
Ok, verstehe.
Herr Lubrenzler.
Sie haben gesagt, seit zehn Tagen haben Sie diese Probleme.
Aber früher haben Sie 50 Hebechwerden?
Ja, ich erinnere mich gut an meine Frau.
Aber in letzter Zeit vergesse ich alles.
Ich habe keine Gedächtnisstörung.
Aber in letzter Zeit habe ich leider viel Leid.
Seitdem habe ich meine Frau verloren.
Ok, verstehe.
Ich war sehr traurig. Ich liebe meine Frau.
Ich war sehr traurig.
Ich habe sie verloren.
Ich liebe meine Frau. Ich war sehr traurig.
Ich möchte immer weinen.
Immer weinen?
Ich möchte weinen, ja.
Wenn ich meine Frau erinnere, weine ich zu Hause.
Gibt es Bilder an der Wand?
Wenn ich sehe, weine ich.
Denken Sie eine Untersuchung nehmen?
Als Therapie?
Mein Sohn hilft mir manchmal.
Jetzt hat er mich hier mitgebracht.
Lebt er allein?
Ja, ich lebe allein, Frau Doktor.
Aber haben Sie Kontakt mit seinen Freunden?
In letzter Zeit habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Normalerweise gehe ich oft spazieren.
Aber in letzter Zeit möchte ich schlafen.
Ich fühle mich müde.
Manchmal fühle ich mich aggressiv.
Manchmal rufe ich.
Mein Nachbar hat gesagt, ich rufe.
Laut spreche ich zu Hause.
Allein spreche ich.
Ich spreche zu Hause selbst.
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich erinnere mich nicht.
Hören Sie gut?
Nein, ich höre nicht gut.
Sie haben auch Lesen, Sie haben auch See und Hörprobleme.
Ich kann sehen, aber ich höre nicht gut.
Mein Nachbar hat mir gesagt, dass der Fernseher sehr laut ist.
Manchmal schaue ich Fernseher.
Aber es ist sehr laut.
Mein Nachbar hat Beschwerden und Klärte über mich.
Hatten Sie Schwindel?
Ist Ihnen Schwindelig?
Nein, nein, ich fühle mich nicht.
Haben Sie Taubeausgefühl oder Krimen oder Missempfindlichkeit?
Nein, normalerweise bin ich ganz gesund, aber ja.
Ok, waren Sie beduscht oder ohnmächtig?
Nein, nein, war ich nicht. Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Ok, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich keine Fieber.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie Erbrechen?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Ok, haben Sie Probleme beim Nachschweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
In der Nacht?
Nein.
Ok, haben Sie Probleme beim Nachschweiß oder Schuhgang?
Ja, ich leide an chronischen Verstopfpunkten, aber ja.
Nachts gehe ich mindestens 3-mal zum Klo, zum Nachschweiß.
Ok.
Wann war Ihr letztes Schuh?
Ja, vor zwei Tagen.
Vor zwei Tagen, ok.
Ok, alles klar, Herr Bränsle.
Ist Ihnen bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bekannt?
Frau Doktor, ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Ja, gut schlafen, ok.
Ja, wegen zu schlafen trinke ich immer einen Tee.
Mein Sohn hat mir einen Tee mitgebracht.
Ja.
Ich trinke einen Tee, aber ich weiß nicht, was der Name ist.
Und ja, mein Stuhl ist sehr hart.
Und...
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, mein Appetit ist gut, aber manchmal esse ich nur einmal pro Tag.
Ich vergesse zu essen.
Ok, ja, ok.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Ja.
Und, haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich leide an Bluthochdruck seit 10 Jahren.
Herzschwache seit 5 Jahren.
Vorher Drüsenvergrößerung seit 15 Jahren.
15?
Ja, und ich leide an Hörstörungen.
Ich höre nicht gut.
Deswegen nutze ich ein Hörgerät.
Hörgerät, ok.
Seit wann haben Sie Benüsten?
Hörstörungen?
Ja, Hörstörungen.
Seit 15 Jahren.
Ok, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Oh, viel, Frau Doktor.
Ich nehme viel.
Ich erinnere mich an Frosemit, Spirolakton und Kandisartan.
Und schlafen, zu schlafen.
Ich trinke einen Tee.
Manchmal nehme ich Schlafmittel.
Und, ja.
Ja.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung dieser Medikamente?
Nein, mein Sohn hat diese Medikamente in der Box.
Ich nehme von der Box täglich.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ok, haben Sie Ihre Medikamentenliste dabei?
Mein Sohn hat meine Medikamentenliste.
Ich möchte von meinem Sohn.
Ok, kein Problem.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, niemals wurde ich operiert.
Ok.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen bei dem Vater oder der Mutter?
Ja, leider sind meine Vater und Mutter wegen einem Autounfall verstorben.
Vor 45 Jahren.
45 Jahren.
Ja.
Wissen Sie, haben Sie oder wissen Sie, hat Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, sie sind vor 40 Jahren verstorben, gestorben.
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran.
Ok.
Sind Sie Raucher?
Ich rauche nicht, Frau Doktor.
Ok.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, niemals.
Sehr gut. Aber trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, sehr selten.
Was meinen Sie? Einmal Provohe oder einmal Prozohe?
Einmal pro zwei Wochen trinke ich ein oder zwei Gläser Wein.
Ok.
Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, niemals.
Ok.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind gerne spaziergegangen.
Ja, aber jetzt treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, letzte Woche wollte ich laufen, aber ich konnte nicht zurückgehen.
Ich konnte den Weg nicht finden.
Mein Nachbar hat mich gefunden und mir mitgebracht.
Ok, verstehe.
Was machen Sie? Was haben Sie beruflich gemacht?
Ich denke, ich bin seit 20 Jahren pensioniert.
Ich bin Rentner seit 20 Jahren, aber ich war Lehrer.
Französisch Lehrer war ich.
Sehr schön.
Haben Sie einen Sohn?
Ich habe drei Tochter und einen Sohn.
Meine Frau war auch Lehrerin.
Wir haben uns in der Schule kennengelernt. Ich liebe meine Frau.
Sehr schön.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich habe Stauballergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Manchmal frustig, manchmal üblich wegen Staub.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich bin immer in Deutschland.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, vermutlich.
Haben Sie einen Unfall in letzter Zeit?
Haben Sie einen Unfall oder haben Sie eine Kopfverletzung in letzter Zeit?
Nein, ich erinnere mich nicht an Frau Doktor.
Herr Brinsla, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Möchten Sie eine Tomographie oder Röntgen von mir?
Ich möchte keine Tomographie.
Röntgen ist gefährlich für mich.
Ich bin sehr gesund. Ich möchte keine Tomographie, Frau Doktor.
Ich verstehe Ihre Angst.
Herr Brinsla, unsere Untersuchung ist nicht gefährlich für unsere Patienten.
Sie haben recht, sie nehmen eine Strahlung.
Aber diese Strahlung ist sehr, sehr gering.
Okay, Frau Doktor. Was habe ich, Frau Doktor? Ich möchte wissen.
Ich habe eine Vermutung, Herr Brinsla.
Aber ich möchte zuerst ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen etwas Geniales sagen.
Bitte warten Sie in den Untersuchungsraum. Ich werde gleich kommen.
Okay, Frau Doktor.
Eine Schwester Silvia kümmert sich um. Ich werde gleich kommen.
Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor.
Okay, hat jemand irgendwelche Fragen? Bitte schön.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich. Bitte schön.
Der Patient heißt Hans Brinsla. Er ist 82 Jahre alt, 1,65 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Brinsla stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 10 Tagen bestehender.
Er hatte eine Gedachnisstörung vor.
Der Patient berichtete, dass er den Weg seiner Haus- und Terminnamen ausübt.
Der Patient berichtete, dass er die Konzentrationsprobleme, Hörstörung und Lesen sehr stört.
Er hatte auch eine Faktorung und Fatigue.
In der vegetativen Anamnese gibt es irgendwelche neurologische Symptome als Begleitsymptomen.
Der Patient hat keine Sefalgie.
Welchen Fachbegriff können wir benutzen für Zittern?
Zittern ist eine Obstubation.
Der Patient hat eine Gewichtsabnahme von 5 bis 10 Kilogramm.
Der Patient hat einen guten Appetit, aber er vergesse Essen und Trinken.
Deshalb hat er Gewichtsverlust.
Lebt der Patient alleine?
Ja, der Patient lebt alleine.
Die Beschwerden sind nach dem Tod seiner Frau aufgetreten.
Die Beschwerden haben sich in der Zeit verschlechtert.
Der Patient hat eine Hörstörung und benutzt eine Hörgerät.
Er nimmt regelmäßig Phorosamid, Spironolacton, Candizartan und eine Schmerzmittel gegen Insomni.
Die Dosis der Medikamente sollte geklagt werden.
Der Patient ist nicht rau und trinkt sehr selten Alkohol.
Einmal pro Woche oder zweimal pro Woche.
Die Dosis der Medikamente sollte geklagt werden.
Der Patient trinkt regelmäßig Sport.
Seit zehn Tagen habe ich Gedächtnisprobleme.
Deshalb möchte er nicht alleine laufen.
In der Familienanamnese würde angegeben,
dass sein Vater und seine Mutter vor 40 Jahren aufgrund eines Autounfalls verstorben sind.
Der Patient hat keine Operation.
Er ist Rentner und Zufa.
Er hat als Lehrer gearbeitet.
Er lebt alleine.
Er ist verwitwet und lebt alleine.
Er hat einen Sohn und drei Tochter.
Er ist vollständig geübt.
Er hat eine Halsstaballergie mit Symptomen Thysis und Yukreis.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf Alzheimer hin.
Oder Demas hin.
Welche Symptome sprechen für eine Alzheimer?
Die Symptome sprechen für eine Alzheimer.
Vergessen.
Names, Becken, Termin.
Kannst du mir amnesisch sagen?
Amnesisch? Ja.
Oder kurzfristig.
Kurzzeitige?
Kurzzeitige Gedankestörungen.
Okay.
Sprechen für Alzheimer.
Und die anderen organischen Symptomen der Patienten haben keine organischen Symptomen als Kopfschmerzen oder Unfallgeschichte.
Deshalb vermute der Patienten Alzheimer ist.
Okay.
Welche Differenzialdiagnosen kommen?
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen Demas oder Hypotheroese, Vitaminmangel, Vitamin B12.
Und Gehirntmörden oder Betra.
Okay.
Ja.
Zur Abklarung der Beschwerden sollten die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
Zuerst werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Dann den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Dann bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob eine neurologische Symptome vorhanden ist.
Wenn die Patienten vorhanden sind, zum Beispiel Hyporreflexe, Hypo- oder Hyperreflexe,
ich beurteile alle Reflexe und ich beurteile auch allgemeinen Zustand der Patienten.
Und ja.
Okay.
Sie haben schon die körperliche Untersuchung gemacht.
Ja.
Ich möchte sagen, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, eine neurologische Untersuchung.
Dann zur Abklarung.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen und einige Laborwerte überprüfen.
Ich würde ein großes Blutbild, ein Sündungparameter und treue Hormone und Vitamin B12 und Vitamin D bestimmen lassen.
Dann einige Elektrolyten auch.
Dann würde ich eine Tomographie des Schadens anfangen.
Warum?
Warum? Um meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen und die mögliche Gehirnstörung oder Probleme auszuschließen.
Dann würde ich eine CT oder MRT veranlassen.
Okay.
Würden Sie diesen Patienten stationieren oder Ambulanz behandeln?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Der Patient befand sich in gutem Allgemeinen Zustand.
Er orientierte sich an Ort, Person und Zeit.
Er hat gesagt, dass sein Sohn sich um ihn kümmern kann.
Ich empfehle den Patienten eine ambulante Therapie.
Was würden Sie als Therapiemöglichkeiten anordnen?
Ich habe nicht viel zu tun.
Ich würde einen neurologischen Konsul anfordern.
Dann würden wir die optimalen Medikamente zusammen verschieben.
Verschreiben.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Behandlung?
Gibt es andere Möglichkeiten für diesen Patienten?
Der Patient lebt alleine.
Das ist eine schwierige Situation für diesen Patienten.
Er kann mit der Zeit ein paar Nahrungsprobleme oder Dehydratationprobleme sein.
Deshalb empfehle ich den Patienten, mit seinen Kindern zusammen zu leben.
Oder eine Betreuung zu empfehlen.
Ich empfehle den Patienten, Betreuung zu nehmen.
Kinderheime oder Pflegeheime können auch andere Möglichkeiten sein.
Ich würde gerne diesen Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Das ist wichtig.
Herr Chefarzt, sind Sie da?
Haben Sie noch andere Fragen?
Ich möchte nicht abklären.
Können Sie uns die Fusion gewünscht haben?
Nein.
Wir können es nicht abklären.
Aber wir können es abklären.
Fusion gewünscht haben.
Man kann es auf die Stomach-Ausgabe machen.
Das ist eine andere Frage.
Okay.
MRT ist eine Abkursung für Magnet-Rosanance-Tomographie.
Es ist eine schmerzfreie und strahlungsfreie Untersuchung.
Mit Hilfe der MRT können wir Weichteile und Weichgebäbe beurteilen.
Gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen der Fusion-Gewünschtheit und der normalen MRT?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich möchte die Fusion-Gewünschtheit MRT aufklären.
Mit Hilfe der Fusion-Gewünschtheit MRT können wir die schmerzfreie Situation beurteilen.
Wie arbeitet diese Untersuchung?
Mit Kontrast?
Nein, kein Kontrast.
Eine Marke mit einer Marke.
Eine Diffusion.
Sie können die Blutung, die Tumor und den Infarkt in 3-5 Minuten beitragen.
Ok, ich kann sagen, dass es gut ist.
Danke schön.
Die Diffusion Magnet Resonanz Tomographie ist ein spezielles Programm für ein spezielles Programm von MRT.
Mit Hilfe der Diffusion-Gebirge MRT können wir Blutung, Apoplex oder Infarkt beurteilen.
Das ist eine schmerzfreie und strahlungsfreie Untersuchung.
Bevor diese Untersuchung geht, sollte der Patient alle Metallgeräte ablegen.
Und in einer Röhre bewegungsstil bleiben.
Wir können sagen ruhig einfach.
Es dauert ca. 20-30 Minuten.
Nach der Untersuchung kann der Patient ganz normal vorwärtsgehen.
Ok, gut.
Ich würde es besser machen, wenn es noch einmal passiert wäre.
Ich hoffe, es wird besser.
Ich würde euch ein bisschen mit der Diffusion beitragen.
Wir sagen immer, dass es die Diffusion nach ist.
Das benutzt ihr sehr selten.
Das benutzt ihr, um zu sprechen.
Das ist nicht möglich.
Ja, ich wollte das auch sagen.
Manchmal sagt man die Stimme in der Frageformat.
Das ist nicht die Stimme.
Manchmal ist es nicht die Stimme.
Und heute haben wir immer noch die Stimme der Stimme.
Ja, das ist die Stimme von Yavuz.
Herr Bränsle ist 82 Jahre alt.
70 Kilogramm schwer, 1,65 Meter groß.
Herr Bränsle hat sich seit zwei Monaten bei uns gestalten.
Er hat sich von Störungen, Verstörungen, depressiv Stimmung eingehört.
Die Frage nach Beüßlosigkeit, Tremor und Parasitez, Hypastese,
hat er verneint.
Hat er Vergeslichkeit?
Entschuldigung?
Ja, Vergeslichkeit.
Sie haben recht.
Der Patient hat über die Abwechselung der Stimmung und die Müdigkeit.
Der Patient hat eine vegetative Anamnese,
die folgende Bekanntheit hat.
Obst, Obstpatient und Pollaküri, Insomni.
Der Patient berichtete über einen Gewichtverlust von 5 Kilogramm innerhalb von 5 Monaten.
Innerhalb von 5 Monaten.
An der Erkrankung, nannte er seit 10 Jahren 5-10 Arteriellhypertonik.
Seit 5 Jahren Hörstörungen.
Deswegen hat der Patient ein Hörstgerät benutzt.
Die Frage nach Operationen hat er verneint.
In der Medikation nimmt er mit Spironolacten, Kandesarten, Schlafmitteln und einem Tee für Schlafstörungen.
Aber die Dosis und die Names der Wirkstoffe sollten geklärt werden.
Der Wirkstoff, die Dosis und die Names der Wirkstoffe sollten geklärt werden.
In der Familienanamnese teilt er mit, dass Vater und Mutter mit 40 Jahren an einem Autounfall gestorben sind.
Er ist nicht Rauchherr, er trinkt gelegentlich ein Glas Wein.
Er ist verwittert, er wohnt allein.
Er hat zwei Kinder. Er ist jetzt renter, aber als Französischer Lehrer für gearbeitet.
Er hat eine neue Stimmung und eine Vergeslichkeit.
Ich würde den Patienten eine neurologische Unterdrückung durchführen.
Nach der Körperliche Unterdrückung würde ich ihn vergeben.
Ich würde ihn in einer Unterdrückung durchführen, um die Diagnose zu verbreiten.
Dabei würde ich ein kleines Blutbild, ein T-3, T-4, T-S-H und noch mehr.
Ich würde den Patienten eine neurologische Unterdrückung durchführen.
Ich würde ihn mit der Therapie optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgegenweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit dieser geplanten Unterdrückung fortfahren.
Bei der neurologischen Unterdrückung kann man sagen, dass die Störungen der Motorik, Sensorik oder andere Funktionen vorliegen.
Würden Sie diese Diagnose in einen Stationär aufnehmen?
Wenn ich meine Verteidigungsdiagnose bestätige, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde den Patienten die Verteidigungsdiagnose überwachen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten einen Venouszugang legen und die Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Behandlung?
Nach der Behandlung empfehle ich den Patienten nicht allein zu leben, weil der Patienten nicht gut…
Was war das Standard für das Leben?
Ich würde den Patienten gut essen und genug Wasser trinken.
Was anderes, Herr Professor?
Herr Kollegen, können Sie uns das City des Schades aufklären?
Ja, ich möchte Ihnen das City des Schades aufklären.
Das City des Schades ist eine spezielle Unterdrückung, mit der wir Gehirn, Inere, Organe und Blutgefäße verteilen können.
Diese Unterdrückung hilft uns bei Erkrankungen wie Tumoren, Entzündungen, Blutungen, Metastasen oder anderen Fremdungen.
Dazu werden die Patienten auf eine Liege legen und die Liege wird eine Ringform mit einer Kamera geführt.
Die Unterdrückung dauert ungefähr 15-30 Minuten, abhängig von der Krankheit.
In manchen Fällen wird der Patient eine Kontrastmitte verbracht.
Für die Unterdrückung müssen die Patienten Metall, Schumuck oder andere Stoffe ablegen.
Die Unterdrückung gibt es in der Röntgenstrahlung, aber die Belastung ist nicht gering.
Nach der Unterdrückung können die Patienten ihre Alltagwege fortsetzen.
Die Unterdrückung ist schmerzfrei und ungefährlich.
Nach der Unterdrückung gibt es keine Beschreibung.
Ja, das war das.
Gibt es alternative Methoden?
Ja, natürlich. Wenn es nötig ist, gibt es viele alternative Methoden.
Zum Beispiel MRT oder andere Röntgen-Destrade.
Gibt es Komplikationen bei der Komplikation der Tomographie?
Ja, es gibt eine Komplikation zum Beispiel allergische Reaktionen gegen Kontrastmitte.
Ok.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du etwas verpasst hast.